there has been an argument in the office
for the past couple of weeks and
Randolph Ramsey in our weekly meeting
this morning wanted to put an end to it
okay he wanted to know which is better
Forte's ax or project cars yeah so you
guys are taking positions on this you
yeah you see we have kind of strong
opinions on both sides one has an easy
one any forza is like a clear winner in
this particularly your massive forts of
fun yeah that's true I mean I'm a
massive project cars fan I mean I like
project cars a lot cuz the great thing
about parts of cars is it's on
PlayStation 4 ok and it's on pc i played
on pc yeah yeah and forts adjust isn't
on those things um and i don't know if
i'd have an xbox if it wasn't for fourth
up I want to talk to you ok for sittin
you first of all
yeah even why you own the car you own
now it's a little bit because I'm more
connected to fourth yeah yeah I own a
pretty badass car because of Forza ok
explain I would say that well I've
always wanted a WRX s abreu and so forth
it just was like yeah you should get one
cuz why not it's awesome and so I got
one with a really absurdly loud muffler
and lowered to the ground it's badass
it makes the worst noises ever yeah how
does it look in the rain okay so forth
okay so drive club still wins the rain
debate doesn't you want to get real
gritty way looks better it just looks
cool but forces rain play like the
actual feeling of the car is great I
know at e3 it felt weird because I
played that demo and I was like this is
way too much but like dude the rain in
in the actual game is really good and
like you feel like you're on the edge of
control the whole time and then you
slide out but then you can actually like
recover really easily using the
controller which brings me to my point
the controller itself this is point one
I guess appropriate if we're going you
know like evolving this directly to
project a project so using an Xbox one
controller the game feels incredible
even compared to five and I was thinking
it was like in my own head I think
enough people have like agreed and
confirmed that like the tweaks they made
to just make it feel great the driving
the way you can cry like overcorrect and
then like bring it back and all with the
thumbstick just is incredible and
there isn't you can you can tweak the
hell out of the controls and project
cars and you pretty much have to to even
get it to feel good at all like it the
default settings even on the Xbox one
version of the game are just awful for
playing on a controller you have to like
tweak all the say and they give it and
like props to them they give you
everything you could tweak everything in
that game which is cool as hell and you
can get all the settings and you bracket
it all in and get it all dialed and then
it's like yeah it still feels ok see
it's weird right because I can't even
argue that point because I play this
game yeah your wheel and pedals which is
the way I love to play racing games yeah
but isn't that better feedback like that
is like racing a car do you even have
that option with something like Forza
you do yeah of course I just have never
done it because I just prefer the
gamepad I think it's for is the only
driving game I've ever played where I
actually felt like the gamepad did a
fantastical really driving with the game
ground because like I play all the old
f1 games and stuff and like playing
those games with a pad just doesn't for
the type of driving you doing that sort
of stuff it doesn't work and that's why
I love on Drive club like the amount of
different disciplines that are in there
and the different types of handling
required like I'll be driving like a
Formula a car which is their sort of
formula one take and I have a project
car sorry project car project cars and
what the message I've got yeah so sorry
and that all the go-kart stuff for that
darling I agree it's incredible it feels
totally right there like there a formula
B cars there like all the supercars
everything feels completely different
the feedback is different the grip is
different like I remember the first time
I tried to drive a Formula a car I went
up through formula C formal B and I got
to formula a and I was trying to like
start on the line my first race in Monza
and I liked going to first gear and the
car just goes nope because I've got my
foot to the pedal yeah pedal to the
metal and it just goes you have to like
teach yourself how each one of these
cars feels with the steering wheel
feedback and I think it's like that's
I've been enjoying project cars so much
because and it's the thing I think that
surprises me is project cars is a racing
name that doesn't have a rewind function
yeah so you have to be really good so I
love the rewind function because like
you know you're playing a game I'm at a
kid
like so yeah the Reformation reports it
lets you once you mess up a little bit
you're able to go back in time a few
seconds and make better choices you
better Drive yeah cuz like you go into a
turn and you want to be like are I'm
going too late APICS this and like this
and see if that works out and then like
your abs doesn't really catch and you
just slide all and usually below the
turn you're like I'll rewind but it's
like I couldn't like play around with
that source stuff in project cars I felt
like although it is that is an
experience to be like completely
concentrating so much in project cars
you're like oh god oh god turn turn turn
but I was playing really conservative
and like I don't know we had this
footage I'm like yeah it's pretty this
game is pretty good actually
it looks gorgeous - yeah like the helmet
cam and stuff - in rocket cars I really
like I because it gives you the depth of
field and like gives you the view of the
inside of the helmet whereas like force
that doesn't really do that yeah like I
not many driving games do that where you
actually see the helmet on your head
in fact Chris and the guys in GameSpot
UK did oculus rift on it and apparently
it's just insane because you've just got
your guy your eyes here like this you
can kind of barely hear the engine as
well it's kind of muffled a little bit
so you really feel like you're like
stuck inside of the engine or I think it
shouldn't bother the wheel I think
that's a good I think project cars does
have like this edge when it comes to
things like that like the fact that you
you're gonna put VR on if you want to
it's like there's customization is just
insane
but the different disciplines are all
like it's it's like pretty good yeah is
that what your sets got a lot going yeah
and it's all like dial in dial and like
you want to do a race weekend it's like
you can qualify you can you know get
your place in the starting grid you can
decide I'm a rock fuel you can practice
it's like you can if you want you can do
like a formula formula like 24 hour
thing yeah or you can do like an f1 race
with like 60 cards how much just to see
laughs but yet so it's like oh crush
it's cool but like and I think that kind
of gives it like this edge yeah
Oh for me as a casual player someone who
is definitely much more comfortable with
Mario Kart than any really hardcore
games project cars looks amazing like I
love looking at screenshots of this game
like it's right so realistic looking and
I think that stands out for just a lot
of players that you're able to get more
out of a PC than you
out of any console and it's going to
look amazing yeah and it certainly does
stand out but here's but like saying
that I think Forza is just like it's the
newest version force of six the cars all
look just great and the difference is
here's an example
in this clip I'm driving an Alfa Romeo
4c and this new track is amazing - it
looks really great so in Brazil is yeah
that's right and that's like I don't
think Alfa Romeos are even in project
cars and I don't think the new Nissan
idx cool track toys in project cars like
uh mice to peruse aren't in project cars
yeah I could go on and on and on and
formula eaters is in Forza yeah and in
project cars it's all fake unlicensed
formula a it's like a made-up thing
basically it's f1 yeah so like yeah
you're right even even there's lotuses I
don't know if it was Lamborghinis in
yeah project I thought matters to you
right a little bit because I'm cut cuz I
come at it from like I like Top Gear I
like them doing weird stuff with really
cool cars and and they or just the films
they make about testing the cars car
passion car passion importance has got
that [ __ ] down here so well and it's
never been better because not only are
you taking these cars out in the rain at
night if they feel better they control
better on the X bar they control great
on that's what there's just so many of
them it's so comprehensive there's so
many tracks now four to five that was a
problem there was like no [ __ ] try
yeah that's true um then six they give
you money like they just give you
millions a million of the course sorry
about sports a five yeah they're like
member how you had to work really hard
for your Subaru BRZ sorry about that now
you can buy like a million dollar car
from the first like wheelspin or
whatever so yeah like I don't know four
to six just seems to be like this
comprehensive package of serious car
[ __ ] like the tracks the cars the way it
controls it's all there and it's all
ready to go and it's like yeah you can't
do a race weekend where you're
qualifying you know running out your pit
crew and your gas and yeah all that gets
your point croissant like yeah it's so
intricate this is just like now I get
top three in this race and if you don't
restart try again
it's like Andy feels the way about four
to six as I do about
project cars it's just like a something
about aniconic comes down to the pro f
vs fifa thing we had last week where
there's a certain element of like
different strokes for different folks
and it comes to car games like have
something feels it's such like a really
difficult thing to nail down like why
one game feels better than another
well the and so these are a lot of big
points if you were who is this game for
like it sounds like they're almost for
different people and so maybe and so who
in the course for who sports project
carter seeking from here for gamers well
no well by default like yeah i mean
how's your cars a game that was
developed by racing fact game fans it's
like a community as I can online share
like they're based in London some of the
team and but like that was built by a
group of people who just love card games
and wanted to make a card game for
themselves forces obviously the opposite
end it's this massive Triple A thing
they've got the licenses but it's
awesome in but people who care about
game yeah cars so I guess it's like one
of them is made for me one of them is
made for the console cried one of those
made for the PC crash I'm one of those
more hardcore and another one is just a
bit more I guess polished or rounded I'd
say because driveclub certainly is like
as it's like peaks and valleys yeah I
don't know about dry high pressure
course project cars you can say John
Klein don't like Troy haha
god damnit that may confuse video I mean
[ __ ] to hear what people in the comments
think though you're so yeah yo your
project your I love Forza like I didn't
think I was gonna like force to six
right because I was like well it's just
few more cars and tracks like whatever
but like I don't know they've just done
enough that it's great it's so good and
like project cars I loved playing it in
the summer because it was like and just
yeah forts a game right now although I
was still playing horizon 2 which is the
best sports game ever me Amy yeah yeah
probably like project cars but I never
felt comfortable I was always like I was
he's like I was always felt like his in
crashed car and then everyone goes you
and every I was because I do and I hit
restart Oh like with Forza even if you
mess a bitter blow thing it's like II we
whined and then you watch the replay and
it's all seamless
that's like you didn't do anything wrong
even where you drifted your way to
success alright you're still in the
force camp hell I'm still in the project
cars camp I mentioned here and why you
guys think in the chat oh let us know
are you a
are you a drunk up five yeah just ribbit
is completely I do you like project cars
you like forward are you waiting for
grunts where's moe and let us know in
the comments below